the og crypto derivatives platform
and the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to another episode of
the leia hill pan show today we have a lot of hot
topics that we are bringing you but before i bring
my guests on i do want to let you know that this
podcast is sponsored by bitmex bitmex is the og
crypto derivatives exchange that has now launched
a spot exchange for you to easily buy and sell all
your different crypto assets especially in a bear
market you need a name that you can trust bitmex
sets the standard for reliability performance
and transparency and has of course proven this
through multiple cycles and has really stood the
test of time so right now bitmex is celebrating
the start of its spot exchange with 1 million
dollars in usd prizes to give away to enter
all you need to do is trade the equivalent of
250 so you could pick up some bitcoin during the
dip you can either enter up to 25 times and one
lucky winner will win 500 000 in bitcoin so to
enter and start buying bitcoin and start your
crypto journey i'm gonna leave all of the links in
the description for you below so you can sign up
and enter and start joining bitmex today also
on this podcast as you know we're having the
conversations that you're sort of not allowed to
have and nobody else is having so a massive thank
you to bitmex because without them we wouldn't
be able to bring you such valuable content all
right guys it's time to do this joining me on the
show today is adam sosnick the host of the sauce
cast podcast and the co-host of the very very
majorly famous and successful youtube channel
valuetainment adam welcome to the show how
you doing you nailed that intro there wonder
great job right i feel like it's a bit of
a mouthful but we got there at the end yeah
sometimes when your brain works so fast you know
the words don't come out i stumble my words all
the time because my brain works so freaking fast
but you crushed it i like that so for those i
don't know who you are because obviously i come
from more of the crypto world um you're a super
interesting guy please just explain briefly your
background and what you do at valuetainment sure
um well i'm uh born and raised in miami i'm a
former jack of all trades miami party boy comedian
who in his early 20s just didn't know what
the hell was going on uh and then i started
seeing all my friends make tons and tons of money
um this is around 2006 2007 right before the
financial crash uh in miami in real estate and i
was like all right i gotta i gotta get involved
something like i can't just be the guy on people's
couch anymore so i transitioned into finance i got
a job as a cold caller for a financial firm hedge
fund and um i'm i crushed it in that business i'm
a financial executive at uh vp of sales at the
same financial firm i started in 06 and from
there i transitioned into being a host and co-host
with valuetainment i've known i've done business
with patrick david shout out to patrick um for
10 years before he recruited me to valuetainment
um but really what like i owe my success to is
that i'm a master networker so i've i'm just
constantly networking i'm just in the right places
right times talking to the right people and uh and
this is something that i'm dealing with patrick on
is that like yeah i made it in money i made it in
finance i've made it in podcasting valuetainment
great great great what do i owe my success to
is just that i understand social dynamics and i
understand networking so the power of networking
yeah so social dynamics is interesting because i
know you talk a lot about that not just finance
and we're going to get to that but you said you
didn't really know what you're doing in your 20s
maybe a little bit your 30s i don't know but
what i do know is you made a good call quite
a few years ago and you bought a lot of bitcoin
so how did you even hear about bitcoin and may i
ask what price did you buy at sure i um i got to
give a shout to adrian one of the um co-founders
of ethernet nft platform um but i i was broke as
[__] at 25. so to all the 25 year olds out there
like life's a marathon especially your financial
life as a marathon most people do not start making
real money into their late 30s early 40s and so i
went from being what's wrong money by the way just
uh i'm saying you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars a year i mean unlike a baseline obviously
you know there's people that made millions and
i'm saying annual income right but um i went from
being again a broke party boy miami i got paid in
drink tickets and fun times and you know clubs and
women and that was great but i would go home and
sleep on like my buddy's couch so in your early
20s i actually actively encourage people to just
[__] about like just figure it out figure out
what you're into but most importantly figure out
what you're not into like where do you not like
i almost went to law school thank god that i
did not end up in law school i just i would
have been a horrible lawyer i don't like to read
all that much especially boring stuff but um
i got a i was always good at because i did stand
up comedy i was always a nightlife person so sales
was always going to be the avenue that i was going
to make money so i went and i got into finance i
what was your initial question how did i get into
that how'd you get into bitcoin oh bitcoin so
i i crushed in finance over the course of 10
years i made x amount of million dollars and
uh when i was 2 35 years old i was going through
a breakup with a british girl no no offense to the
brits out there you're great you're lovely we're
still friends but i was like all right i've got
all this money i'm free i'm single what the hell
do i want to do with my free time what i call
chilling so i've developed like the six step plan
to understanding your money right and step six is
when you are chilling chilling is when you own
your time you don't have to wake up and run off
to work or do anything just what do you want to do
today it's your life right most people when i ask
them what do you want to do if you're chilling
i say if you were chilling you had millions of
dollars in the bank whatever the number is that
whether it's a million 10 million 100 million
dollars what would you do with your free time
if you were quote unquote chilling and everyone
says the same three things number one you want to
travel number two you want to um pursue a passion
number three you want to give back and donate
your time and the last one that most people want
to do is leave a legacy whether that's with your
family whether that's philanthropically whether
that's with the company like leave a legacy so i
said all right what's my challenge i've already
partied i'm from miami i've already partied enough
for 10 lifetimes i've already traveled the world
i've had a good time now what the hell do i want
to do and i started a show to teach millennials
basically how to save that money and i uh invested
into starting up a show much like you're doing
here right um but i had some capital and this was
right around the time 2016 to answer your question
uh i started hearing about bitcoin more and
more and more and more and my buddy adrian
was like yo bro like let me get 10 grand i was
like for what he's like for bitcoin man i'm like
bitcoin bitty bops crypto blockchain i didn't know
none of it i just called it bitty bops and uh let
me get 10 grand all right fine whatever hey let
me get another 10 grand i'm like alright cool this
is your best friend asking for money he's never
asked me for money and 50 grand later i'm like all
right what the [__] is this bitcoin thing but
i trust him you asked what price i got it at um
what was the price in 2016 2017 i don't was it
before the pump was it before the it was before
before before it hit 18 and then crashed was
that the number yeah yeah yeah okay so before
that okay so with my background in finance because
i usually i'm a big stock investor that's s p 500
index fund like you know dollar cost averaging
that's just very very um normal for me um
and uh bitcoin crashed and he's like so what do
you want you want to sell it i'm like no that's
not how what you do with an asset class you
believe in you buy and hold and then i found
out it's not hold it's huddle exactly right
okay so then with my show i started basically
the way i started my show is i went around
interviewing all the financial advisors that
i deal with right so because i for my hedge fund
i'm basically a financial wholesaler i deal with
um estate planners financial advisors insurance
agents brokerages and they come to me and for what
my niche is right but so i would go to all these
financial conferences and interview the best of
the best brightest minds in finance insurance
investments whatever and then through adrian
because he was working with uh crypto trader on
cnbc yes with ran uh what's rand's last name nuna
rand and uh he would get me access to all these
bitcoin events and and easily enough they were
a lot of them were in florida um so i would go to
these events and i would interview these bitcoin
enthusiasts and quite admittedly i thought it
was like it was weirdos and this is 2017. it was
not you know it's still not that cool it's still
not it's much cooler now like you're at the
bitcoin conference here like logic's performing
steve aoki like they're throwing banger concerts
right but then it was like weird fringe people
like forex people you know i don't even know if
they were libertarians at that point i don't
know but it was very new and admittedly i was
like i'll go because it's interesting but it's i
was i was almost laughing i don't want to like be
disparaging but i was like i went to film content
i wasn't going because these people are changing
the world i do have a different perspective on it
now because your perspective can change when your
information that you're um digesting changes
so yeah that's when i learned about kryptonite
i remember i interviewed this one lady and she's
like i left my man and i fell in love with bitcoin
and i'm all about i'm like all right like she's
just i was like this lady is leaving her man to
go after bitcoin so that's when i started
realizing all right this is a real thing
and then obviously during covid and we saw what
happened with bitcoin but yeah i got involved in
2016-17 but not because i was a believer because
i believed in the person that was pitching me
so you said you have a different perspective now
has that changed well i mean if your perspective
hasn't changed since 2017 and it's 2022 like
on everything whether that's politics or that
business whether that's relationships whether
that's the economy whether that's you know just
the global marketplace whether it's covet whether
it's china whether it's [__] bitcoin well what's
your perspective on bitcoin now well i think
it's again um if you believe in the asset class
you're there for the long term so you know i just
bought like i told you i asked you the other day
i'm like should i buy bitcoin and you're like
yeah buy some and i asked you where you thought
the low mark would be i thought you said like
maybe like 15-ish potentially okay potentially
so i bought like three more bitcoin at 20. so
and i asked adrian um ethernet guy i was like
should i buy more because i'm just sitting on cash
here and uh he's like hold off not not yet so um
i i i've i follow what the big boys do and
i remember when like tesla started buying
bitcoin elon musk and micro strategies michael
saylor who i've interviewed and you know a lot
of the people that were dabbling and dipping
their toes into bitcoin the number that i saw
was between three and eight percent so the big
boys i'm talking massive hedge funds banks you
know teslas of the world three and eight percent
of their cash reserves so i'm i've employed that
exact same strategy so if i've got a hundred grand
i'll take you know three to eight percent of it
and pump that into bitcoin so it all depends on
what your you know is palatable to you so let's
talk about those strategies you're the finance
guy you set up this podcast so that you could
help educate millennials about finance so in your
opinion where do you think people are going wrong
when it comes to money what don't they understand
yeah i mean i say this all the time is that we
all go to school we take the same boring classes
algebra biology chemistry trigonometry i took wood
shop zero percent chance that i'm cutting wood
in my life and but they don't teach you about
money they don't teach you money classes they
don't take you teach you money management they
don't teach you about investing they don't teach
you about the stock market they don't teach you
about taxes they don't teach you about any of
the principles that you're going to need when
you're a grown up and it's a part of it is because
a teacher who makes 40 50 grand a year they don't
know what the hell they're doing they're teaching
history or algebra or calculus but there's no
classes like that so i've always i go to schools
and i speak at these schools and i'm like show
of hands if you guys understand appreciation
depreciation how money works stock market and like
you have 10th graders 11th graders they're like
yeah i don't know what you're talking about
but those same kids know about crypto
these days though so that's the difference
crypto has basically pierced through to be part
of the pop culture nomenclature that kids kind of
understand the problem um and this is the the
good and the bad of bitcoin is that you don't
start with bitcoin you need to start with like
understanding cash flow budgeting have a game plan
for your money getting out of debt not getting
into debt understanding having cash reserves right
most of americans don't have 10 grand i
tell people to have 10 grand to your life
before you start trying to become a millionaire
right like there's levels to this you go from a
thousand to 10 000 to 100 000 to a millionaire you
don't go from a thousand dollars to a millionaire
like it's just not going to work out well for you
so crypto and crypto bitcoin has done a great job
in getting people to like understand finance
but you know you gotta crawl before you walk
walk before you run run before you run a marathon
some people these days especially young people
just think that it's easy you buy dogecoin and
you're overnight millionaire doesn't work like
that but what aren't people understanding you
said most people don't have 10 grand to their
name so why um like in what way are they so
financially illiterate yeah i think people are
i almost said people are smart and then i
caught myself people some people are smart
most people are smart but if there's a difference
between book smart going to school taking classes
and understanding that how money works
understand the difference between wants
and needs understanding what a basic budget is
right one of the things i always say about having
a budget is like the only thing worse than doing a
monthly budget is not doing a monthly budget right
so if you have 10 grand coming in every month
and you have 10 grand going out every month
you know it's not how much you make it's
how much you keep so um it's a lot of so
this is what i'll give you this 50
of money management is knowledge
right i understand i want to get out of debt
i want to make money i want to say i get it
but the other 50 is behavioral are your actions
following what your knowledge is it's almost like
yeah like for instance 70 of americans are
overweight whatever it is they know that they
shouldn't have four cheeseburgers for dinner they
know that they shouldn't get wasted and have pizza
right like i used to do back in the day in south
beach like yeah and i got fat for a little bit
like you know that you need to work out so
you know these things just like with money
you know you need to save you no need to get off
debt you know that with your tax refund for five
grand you could either pump that into a roth ira
or go to [__] mykonos but your are your actions
mirroring what the knowledge tells you to do and
most people don't do that so how do people get
it right yeah that's the million dollar question
right so i mean it comes with it comes with having
the knowledge base so if you just don't know how
to budget or how cash flow works or what interest
rates are like yeah read a book there's like the
millionaire next door how to get rich think and
grow rich right there's um you know the richest
man in babylon there's tons and tons of books that
you can read for knowledge but if you're not you
know performing what the knowledge tells you to do
it's like how many people read exercise books
that's great you know how to do it but are you
getting in the gym most people need a kick
in the ass and say no don't go out saturday
night bro you're broke as [__] stay in the
house like if you oh i do it i want to go out
i want to meet a girl it's like yeah you know
well if you do meet the girl and you're broke
like how is that going to serve you so are
your is your knowledge aligned with your
actions most people don't have the knowledge and
certainly don't have the actions to mirror what
the knowledge should tell them to do so it's a
learning curve it's a learning process and the
quicker you can learn it the better off you'll
be because life gets more expensive as you go on
your 30s are more expensive than your 20s your
40s are more expensive than your third because
you're going to grow up you've got a mortgage
you've got kids you've got family life's only
to get more expensive so the quicker you can learn
basic financial lessons have a decent foundation
for your home your financial home the better off
you'll be in the long run at 30 like i went from
broke as f at 25 to being a millionaire at 35 okay
did i do anything magical that would i did i you
know i didn't buy dogecoin and just wish on a star
i put in the work i had work ethic i networked my
ass off okay i hung around the right people any
like if i had a you know let's say i made 50 grand
a month because i've had some amazing months where
i've made hundreds of thousands of dollars and
i've had months where i've made nothing but over
the course of time if i made a hundred grand in a
month like the other day like this is a story we
tell in the podcast um i made 150 grand in april
okay one month and pat goes patrickbetdavid goes
what did you buy and i go yeah i bought a new suit
because how much of that cost 500 bucks because
that's it i actually got some white shirts at h
m i spent like probably like another 80 bucks so i
spent 580 bucks versus i could have spent 50 grand
i could have gone to the club i could have bought
bottles i could have bought a ridiculous car
ultimately who i am like i just realized
everyone's you know we're all learning who
we are every year like if you're not adjusting and
learning i've realized that i'm a minimalist who
has become a millionaire so i don't spend a lot of
money on myself when i do have like a girl in my
life i tend to spend a lot of money on her because
i don't really care like i could buy uh oh [__]
i'm sorry you're fine what could you buy gideon
um i could have bought a rolex i but i bought
bitcoin okay i could have bought um a ridiculous
car i haven't had a car in 11 years i'm like
i'm sort of redefining what it is to be wealthy
like again with the children thing i like to own
my time i don't i don't i don't need like luxury
goods i don't need to have ridiculous cars and
chains to tell me all right you're wealthy it's
like i look at my bank accounts like life's going
okay i'm very comfortable in my own skin and i
feel like a lot of people especially millennials
you're familiar with the acronym henry's no
high earners not rich yet millennials so 50
of millennials are making 100 grand or more
a year are living paycheck to paycheck that
is the exact opposite of the stuff that i condone
right if you're making 100 a year live off 50 of
it have a roommate you're a millennial you're 28
years old whatever like don't grow up too quick
and save that money right so that's like my
entire catchphrase to save that money because
if you start saving now and start investing
now and hotel bitcoin now by the time you're 40
you're chilling the rest of your life the problem
you ever hear what bernie sanders says about um
boomers no what did he say okay so i'll do like a
little bernie sanders impression right there well
like when he was running for president not that
i'm bernie sanders advocate but i do think he's um
quite humorous he goes do you understand that 50
of baby boomers have zero save for retirement zero
so you're gonna you know what happens if you have
zero save for retirement is because people are
living longer they used to die at 65 that's why
social security kicks in at 62 or 65 you'd live to
67 years it's like you have an insurance plan for
the government for two three years okay now you
live to 80 90 100 no problem you want to be on the
government plan for the next 30 40 years not me
so um the quicker you understand that you're
going to need money way longer than you think
the like the biggest emphasis is understanding
the difference between your wants today and your
needs tomorrow so right now my mom who's
you know doing healthy she's 71 years old
she doesn't have money thank god she has a
successful son that pays her bills straight up
but a lot of people are gonna be dealing with that
problem especially if your parents haven't saved
that money so um if your parents haven't done
it you're gonna probably have to do it for them
yeah it's a sad reality um but i'm happy that your
mum has you that's great that's important she sent
her love by the way oh thank you i'm not that
i'm fair for anything but there you go um okay so
the game is changing you've been
in the finance business for a while
um you're 41 now you said so it's been
a while so how has the game changed and
how do people make money now is is it really
online is online the best way to start earning
for young people yeah well i mean the barriers of
entry have all been taken down right so i say this
all the time that you know um you know in the
90s uh not that i was in finance in the 90s but
i watched all those movies you know boiler room
wolf of wall street which was you know obviously
10 years ago but based in the 90s all those movies
wall street greed is good the whole thing if you
wanted to trade stock or even crypto for that
matter didn't exist but let's use today's terms
you would have to pick up the phone one of
your old school zack morris phones shout out
to the saved by the bell watchers out there do
you even know what that is yes i watched okay
um rest in peace screech did he die oh yeah when
was it last year oh wow i had no idea there you go
sorry dustin diamond i apologize um but you'd
have to pick up the phone make a call to your
stock broker or they would cold call you you know
like the pink sleeps pink sheets that they talked
about in uh wolf of wall street and you would have
to negotiate what you wanted to spend in the stock
market with some shady guy on the other side of
the phone not that all financial advisors are
shady but this was the reality of the 90s and this
is how jordan belford wolf of wall street made all
his money by scamming people on the phone and
employing hundreds and hundreds of other people
to make calls on the phone but now that person you
don't need that person anymore you could log on to
a variety of exchanges and just get
online yourself you know whether that's a
robo-advisor a fee based broker or whether that's
a you know bit max or any of the crypto accounts
out there crypto.com or uh f what is it f x
bit max bit no okay bitmaps it's only bitmaps
i don't know i'm naming other things clearly
that's the only thing that's going on
um but the bearer of entry is now gone just like
in media just like in social media that's why
valuetainment is so successful we didn't have
to wait around for us to get plucked out by a
network you know cnbc or nbc or fox and say hey
you guys are great no we're just going to start
our own thing i mean just look at you like you i
know you're on media networks but you can't count
on that unless you want to be a full-time media
network uh pundit so you're just starting out
so the barrier entry is no longer there crypto um
media all that so uh you don't need to go through
the typical channels so young people have an
amazing ability to kind of use tech to their
advantage so have at it guys well what do you do
if you don't have any capital to start off with um
you know you you can't invest in the business
whether it's you know hiring a studio like this
or whether it's um hiring employees what do you
do if you don't have any capital i mean if you
don't have any capital what the hell can you do i
mean you have to work people are scared of working
these days so you know since the pandemic how
many people were unemployed getting out of uh
just like copping out just yeah just work ethic
is a thing that i don't know for whatever reason
is not is it frowned upon i mean you're younger
than me is work ethic frowned upon these days
like i had to work my uh to get to the point
of making going from making my first year that
i got involved in finance i made five thousand
dollars in one year leia my next year i made a
hundred grand the year after that i made 250 the
year after that i made 500 then on and then but i
started at five grand why because i was dialing
for dollars like crazy i wasn't doing like the
jordan belford shady stuff because i'm with the
same firm five years later we're great we're good
finra approved the whole thing but you have to
work yeah you know so hard work you know they say
don't work hard work smart yeah up to a certain
point work your ass off work hard and then once
like you've lifted the boulder up the mountain
then you can start working smart you can't just
start working smart if you have no work ethic and
no money so sometimes just got to put in the work
whatever it is yeah i mean i guess it's that
whole participation trophy thing which has sort
of ruined the younger generation and everyone is
sort of entitled and thinks you know things should
just come to them and why do i have to work hard
can't you know the government give me a loan to
start investing in my company and the government
i'm i'm not speaking on behalf of me that's for
sure by the way i wore this for you why because
it's the colors oh it's a bitcoin thank you
yeah well it's a bit yellow but it's a good
color i don't have what is it bitcoin orange
yes yeah orange i apologize no you're good okay
so yeah you know what you're talking about is
very much um the modern day entrepreneur
right that's what you're talking about um
so how do you get into that mindset because
i think a lot of people um are afraid
to leave that nine to five um you know maybe
they've built up capital so how do you switch that
mindset well you don't have to be an entrepreneur
you could also be an intrapreneur what is that
i'm familiar with that i've heard it but okay so
i'm actually an entrepreneur i've never started
a business that's not my mo i'm a networker i'm a
sales guy like they send me out to hunt and bring
in leads and make contacts and make friends and
make connections and make all sorts of um you know
putting fluttering out there that my know your
skill set i think like you don't have to be the
person that puts down the capital that starts the
business that has the idea you can be the number
two guy or you can be the number three guy or girl
or whatever at your company you don't have to be
the number one something that patrick and i always
talk about is know if you're a number one or not
okay so you could be a number four you could
be at a fortune 500 company and be a number
eight and have an amazing exit you don't have
to be the number one i learned that i'm not
like my best skill set is not the number one
because i don't want to deal with overhead
i want to enjoy my weekends i don't want to have
the stress like there's certain like just certain
traits that an entrepreneur has to have like
you're familiar with the iceberg effect like a lot
of people only see the top yes of the success like
the money the cars the women the whatever it is
they don't see the bottom half of the glacier the
iceberg that's the hard work the perseverance the
late nights the rejections all that stuff and
whether you're an entrepreneur an entrepreneur
you're still going to deal with that but the
entrepreneur shout out to the entrepreneurs
out there they lay it all on the line okay like if
your business fails they fail right if you're an
entrepreneur you have a business within the
business so whether or not like in my financial
firm i don't own the firm i'm the top sales guy
but i don't have overhead i don't have staff i
don't have underwriters i don't have to pay the
taxes i don't have to pay the rent like that's not
my like i don't want to deal with that i want to
crush it i want to make money take my commissions
i'm out so if you find yourself saying well i
don't know what i want to do like i don't want
to do the nine to five thing but i don't know
if i'm cut out to be an entrepreneur you can
there's a middle ground called the intrapreneur
that um you can build the business and work you
know side by side with the ceo founder what have
you and be the entrepreneur so you don't need to
again quit your nine to five or take out a loan
from the government or whatever you can just find
a business that you align with and go crush it
with that person and by the way like the most one
of the more famous entrepreneurs of all time is
steve ballmer steve ballmer microsoft bill gates
hello still steve ballmer is the top 20 richest
people in the world right now he owns la clippers
he was never the ceo he's never the founder he was
i mean he might at one point been the ceo but he
didn't start the company he wasn't the number
one so he was an entrepreneur who grew look at
um uh apple uh tim uh what i'm like losing i'm
having a trump moment tim tim apple tim tim
tim tim cook yeah thank you gideon gideon there
you go amazing producer like you remember when
trump was like i'm here with tim apple and
he's like i didn't say tim apple he's like
no we caught it on camera you're not talking about
he said to him apple i haven't seen that anyway
tim apple didn't found tim cook didn't found
apple right right but he worked his way up so
uh the new um person at google the new person
at twitter like well we'll see what happens with
elon yeah but all these people they don't have to
found the company you don't have to be the number
one entrepreneur you can work your way up and you
know nothing's gonna happen no i think that's a
great advice actually um i think that makes a
lot of sense it's important to know what your
skill sets are and um work and like monetize that
and focus on that but your content is changing
a little bit right so you're initially talking
about finance but i've noticed you're speaking
a lot with the guys from fresh and fit you've had
rolo who i recently had on the show you've spoken
a lot with him um talking a lot about dating and
everything like that um so talk to me about what
you're trying to do why are you talking about
dating and how why are you interested in that
as opposed to finance yeah well it's thank you
the number one i think it's just more interesting
it is interesting i like i enjoyed a lot
more but um i think there's a need for both
and i think there's a need for someone who
understands both right like so for instance rolo
good friend he understands intersectional dynamics
better than anyone in the world but he's not a
money guy right fresh and fit shout out to those
guys they crush it they interview tons of women
um they're not money guys you know they they
they're learning myron especially i think he's
investing more in real estate fresh is more
buying like jewelry and cars more power to you
but there's not a lot of money guys out there
talking about relationships because for any guys
out there like why are you making money okay
so on the surface so you can pay your bills
but then like once you're past the bills you know
they say that the most people need to make 75 000
a year to be quote unquote happy we can have a
whole conversation of what happiness is but um
once you reach a certain level why are you making
all this money uh to keep up with the joneses to
have a nice car to impress women what's like
your motivating factor to having this money
because it's not just like yeah bro i made more
money than you it's like what like a competitive
situation with your boys a lot of times you need
money to uh take out women and women if there's
one underlying theme with women women like to have
fun like cyndi lauper girls just want to have fun
i think that's very true girls just want to have
fun whether that's with a rich guy whether that's
a broke guy who's good looking whether that's with
a cool guy like whether it's a funny guy like why
do you think funny guy's comedian i used to do
stand-up comedy i used to get girls when i was
broke as [__] because i was funny right girls
want to have fun the the the other side of that is
having fun costs money mm-hmm going on trips costs
money going to nice dinners costs money going to
freaking disneyland costs money like going out
costs money so you know the intersection where
i say is like my show sas cast is where romance
meets finance right where money and relationships
meet because there's an intersection right there
like show me like you know i'm sure there's a lot
of crypto people out there there's some nerds out
there that not in that crypto people are nerds but
that have made a lot of money whether it's drop
shipping social media but they just sit at a
computer all day i don't care how much money they
have they're never going to go out there into the
real world and meet a beautiful woman or you know
conversely a guy whatever and what you're into but
it you need both okay so that it's it's very
interesting to me and i think a lot of men
especially young men really need help these
days when i was growing up let me tell you
something leia back in the day in the in the
90s early 90s you had to have [__] balls why
because you needed to pick up the phone a
landline dial the number her father will pick
up the father would pick up and hey can i speak
with britney who's this this is adam from her
class what do you want from her i gotta talk to
her about homework i'm i don't it wasn't homework
hold on right and you're you're dealing with
the [__] father knowing that you're calling
to take his daughter out so you had to maneuver
like in a totally different way that exists
today today you get a girl's snapchat instagram
whatever just dm them hey what up you up whatever
that's a lot different than when guys my age late
30s early 40s had to go out and quote unquote
hunt so men these days they have it very easy in
certain ways you just get a girl's instagram slide
in the dm but that doesn't mean you have game
in real life that doesn't even know how to like
maneuver when the father shows up or whether
that's a metaphor for whatever hurdle gets thrown
your way so uh you know rollo talks about the lost
boy generation that men aren't being men anymore
because a lot of times it's too easy they expect
overnight results they don't want to put in the
work this goes back to work ethic so you know
i i i believe as being the oldest millennial
are you a millionaire yeah the oldest monster
yeah were you born 1981 right so the i'm the
youngest millennial you're what year 96 okay so
like we're i'm the oldest you're the youngest
so being the oldest millennial it's actually a
term if you're born in 1980 or something 78 to 82
you're what's called a zenial you're on the fringe
of gen x and millennials right you can if you grow
up a little too soon you might be a gen xer if
you took a while to grow up like a miami party
boy like me you might be more of a millennial but
you understand what it was like when you had to
dial the phone and get her girls like on
the phone you know her father picks up so
you understand the difference of what was going
on in the 90s before social media but you also
have a good grasp on what's going on now so gen
z on the other hand they've never had to have
land lines or deal with any of the hurdles
that comes with all that stuff everything's
at a press of a button so i think i have a
unique knowledge like a new unique skill set
that kind of bridges like the old school
mentality and the new school mentality
because a lot the what's the whole knockout hey
what's up boomer your average 60 year old isn't
going to understand that whereas your average 18
year old has no idea what it was like in the 90s
and look what year did the iphone out really come
out like what year did it really make a splash i
was in school we had the blackberry first and then
with the cars yeah we all blackberries 2000 and
no it was later i think like 2011 everyone
really got an iphone that's when we switched
yeah late 2000s from what i recall like 2007 2008
think about that so 15 years ago we didn't have
any of what we have now no social media i mean
people weren't on the internet but it was like
like maybe you're on aol like in some weird
room or like you know or but it's just so new
and it's just we don't know what the
future's gonna hold but i feel like
you know if you don't understand history
you're doomed to repeat it so you know there
there's a there's a certain knowledge base that
you have if you're in your late 30s early 40s
that maybe someone doesn't have in
their early 20s or certainly someone
who's kind of like missed the boat like i have
friends who are in their early 40s mid 40s
that dude they got no clue what's going on with
social media they completely missed the boat
so the older you know older millennials late
30s early 40s the ones that capitalized on
social media they're killing the game right now
whereas people maybe a year too older than them
they're like i don't know all that they're lost
in the sauce they're still maybe on facebook and
that's it so it's a learning curve so your podcast
is would you say it's sort of to empower men and
teach men how to have game how to do better in
in today's dating scene i think that's part of it
especially because i'm not like the expert on that
i have a lot of expertise in that i grew up in
miami and south beach i've owned bars club
promoter the whole thing i've been around
women like my entire life but that's not what i've
dedicated my life to business-wise socially yeah i
know as much as anyone you've mentioned i've been
out and partied more than any of them and i can
the pop culture scene that i've been in because of
south beach and because of my inroads in the nba
is like way like way further advantage than a
lot of people that talk about this but some like
someone like rolo writes books about this stuff
so i have people like him on my show and a panel
so as an example i'll have a feminist on um a
housewife a intersexual dynamics expert like rolo
fresh and fit on and like have them all debate
and i'm there just to kind of curate answers
and i don't like my my whole like i'm very
chameleon-like like i could be funny and
like cool and chill or i could be like you know
listen [__] like you know here's the deal like
i can kind of go with the flow and that's
what goes back to the power of networking
is understanding like who you are in the social
dynamic structure but on my show i'm more of like
a host willing to understand all sides rather
than kind of like there's people that this is
my opinion and i can just go on hours for that
that's not me so what have you learned what is
some of the biggest problems in the dating scene
right now um the the number one thing that comes
to mind has to do with women um and understanding
what has changed because of feminism and this was
not something that i was aware of a year ago and
it's something that i talk about all the time is
that um you know a stat came out recently and fact
checked this all you want 45 percent of working
women between the ages of 25 and 45 right by the
year 2030 so in eight years from now 45 of women
are going to be non-married and childless okay
so women that have been empowered by feminism and
that's awesome work make your money your equal all
that love women like women are the number one and
this is going to be controversial the number one
commodity in the world i don't mean that like in a
like in like a possession type of way diamonds
jewels you know gold bracelet women are the
number one thing people go to wars over women
okay so i respect women i love women like 100
but women have to understand what their role is
in society for millions of years there was the
hunter-gatherer society and the women was raising
the house raising the children taking care of the
home being a good mother the most important role
of a woman is to be a mother born on full stop but
now women can make money you know in 1980 there
was a movie that came out working nine to five
dollar part you've seen that working not too fast
like that whole thing and like that sparked very
much a feminine revolution i can make my money i
can do my own thing okay great and i'm not saying
that all women you know are monetized sexually
but a large swath of them are so now we talked
about the barriers to entry look at only fans
now i can't tell you how many girls i meet that
do only fans really i've never met a girl that
doesn't oh my god i mean you've been to miami
once or twice they're out there okay and like
and they're not gonna just come out and say hey
what do you do for work i do only fans like well
you know i model i do whatever but interesting
the more money that a woman makes so they talk
about this all the time guys don't care how much
money a woman makes i had this conversation with
a girl that i'm kind of talking to these days
she's like yeah you know i um i'll tell you a
story so uh we were at um this was last week
um there was a big event in miami called
rolling loud you familiar with that
huge hip-hop festival and travis scott was at
the after party at a place called 11. familiar
with that i've heard of it okay so we go there and
um i get us in there's six of us group good like
i know the guy we're good you know networking
the power of networking like we're good there's
a huge line outside we get in the girls are like
super impressed like that was awesome so we go in
and um the girl goes let's go take out a thousand
dollars and make it rain i go well your money or
her money well right so i go okay where are we
going to get this a thousand dollars and there's
like an atm type it's like a teller it's not like
like a normal atm you go to like the strip club
teller uh to take the money out she goes okay go
go and i'm like i'm taking the money out you're
the one that wants to take the money out this is
the girl you're dating no like a girl that like i
was hanging out like a friend like a girl like red
flag bro yeah well that's what my nickname for her
um that's your nickname red flag i'm not even
joking so i say um well no i'm not taking out
like no i'm good by the way it's like five
in the morning i'm ready to go home anyway
and she goes well let's just do 500. and i go
well i'll tell you what whatever you take out
i'll take out look at that so whatever you want
to do i'll do but like meet me halfway don't
just expect the guy this is a problem so some
guys they're either going to be too broke to go
consider taking out a thousand dollars some guys
are going to just be like well she's really hot
and my only way to you know ingratiate myself with
this girl is proving to her that i can do this
or there's some guys that are like yeah i have
the money but i'm not doing [__] like like
that's not was she hot yeah late twenties okay
so but the point is this when i was like well
why don't you go take out half and i'll take it
off she's like no you know whatever and then we
got into a whole conversation oh god about
um well we we you know we gotta take care of
these girls you know and i was like what do you
mean take care of these these are strippers and
fast forward she does only fans okay so there's
this mindset that like girls they're doing it
they take care of other girls whatever i was
like yeah i don't that's not my thing at all
like you do realize that my entire brand is save
that money for these exact type instances she goes
no i get it i get it i'm like but back to my point
women are making more money than ever by the way
this girl lives in a sick place she's making a ton
of money i'm sure she has more than one only fan
if you know what i mean like she's doing very well
but i don't like the difference between a man and
a woman so let's say i make a half a million
dollars a year um and let's say a girl makes
a hundred grand a year or even a half a million
dollars a year for that matter the guy's gonna be
let's say we live together we go the guy's paying
for pretty much everything paying the rent we go
on vacation i'm taking care of the vacation if
we're going for dinners i'm paying for dinners
like i'm not asking you to do anything correct
other than just be pretty and pleasant and
have a good time and have a great attitude whereas
the girl whatever she makes she's not spending
on the guy so you asked like the initial like
dating relationships like guys need to understand
how this works with their money right so most
like fresh and fit always talk about this
like i don't care what a girl does they say that
i'm like no i care what she does but i don't care
like like the amount of money she makes because
she's not spending that on me it's a guy's role
to spend it on her so and you agree with me i
agree with you yeah how do you agree with me
ask me a more specific question so do you like
why do you agree that guys spend the money and
girls don't spend the money on the guy well i mean
i personally value traditional gender roles right
okay um and so i enjoy the fact like i think
that's what men should do and i think that
okay because like because i agree with you when
you said that i think the most beautiful thing
a woman can do is be a mother and raise children
and have a family and excuse this term but serve
her husband right like i personally think
that that's sort of how um so serve as in
like make his life um as easy as possible right
because he's the one that's paying for everything
um and my brother's in the room and we were
talking about this earlier today gideon goes
gideon goes i just want my woman to cook me bacon
and eggs and i'll pay for everything all i'm
asking is for bacon and eggs in a clean house
and it's true is it that hard to ask for them
because i think it's true look if he's going
to pay for everything then why are you upset
and i did this video the other day and the video
was saying um you know men go out to work every
single day um and women are trying to complain and
compete and all he's asking is you know relax stay
home please just be a nurturing mother i will pay
for everything and um women got really offended
because they said that it's not relaxing to be
a mother right have you ever had a child layer
it's hard to take care of a child i'm sure but
i can tell you as someone that's got a business
that it's that i imagine it's harder to be an
entrepreneur than it is to be a mother having an
entrepreneur having responsibilities like that
having to make that money without um you know
because you don't know how you're gonna live the
next day there's nobody else to pay your bills i'm
the only one that pays my own bills um you know
and so that's very stressful and i think that's
more stressful than raising children and having
a man that will that will guarantee a roof over
your head and a financial system sorry not a
financial system a judiciary system which will
guarantee that right because if you get
divorced then don't worry you've got the
kid and the money so you literally have it all
sorted as a woman basically do you think it's um
easier these days to be a man or a woman i think
it's oh okay so i i somewhat do think it's 50 50.
um i think if you're a high value man
which is you know like rich successful
um you know you've got game you're exciting you're
fun you're smart you're intelligent you're strong
right the whole usual spill i think if you're that
then you own the world right um i think what makes
you a high-value woman in the red-peeled world
will go down that that route um is young and
beautiful and sweet and all that but that that
can't last so at least like men can you know
because people age right so men have control over
their over their sexual market value whereas women
don't have control because time ticks on so that's
why i think it's easier to be a man although i do
understand that men have to become and women can
just be i respect that and i get that but i think
given the fact that you can actually do something
about your value as a man makes it easier to be a
man what do you think well by the way there's no
clear-cut answer but i'll give you my opinion this
by the way this is way more exciting than just
talking about investing in 401ks well we do it all
i'm just saying like this this is the reason that
this type of um content i think is so um valuable
because there's so many different opinions on this
there's not a lot of different opinions on finance
i get should you do in stock market you should do
real estate but like you know but so what i always
say is yeah it's [__] hard to be a guy i'm sure
right so like it took me multiple years 10 years
to go from broke as a joke you know to having
money to being a quote unquote high value whatever
the hell that term you know signifies but having
money like being successful having game women the
whole thing what percentage of men get to that
point maybe 10 okay but at least a man knows
what he needs to do like my whole thing is clarity
no matter what situation i just need some clarity
like help me get clear on what we're trying to
establish here and for a man it's very clear
make money you know be good looking be a gentleman
be suave like be good to your lady be good to your
mom like have what sauce like have a little bit
of like so i mean that's literally my name sauce
like have a little something going on like
but that's not easy to do but again clarity
you know what the [__] you got to do like
run that way run through the wall kick ass
and if you work hard enough and if your mindset is
right you'll get there cool so for a man it's hard
but at least there's clarity the problem with
women is that there's a lack of clarity should
you be a boss babe an empowered woman and like i
don't need no man kind of vibe or should you be
a housewife reliant on a man raising kids being
a good mother and a being a good wife which one
well you're going to have half of women saying
one thing and having half of women saying the
other whereas you have pretty much 100 of men
saying kick ass make money have success so which
one is it if you're looking for clarity it's much
easier to be a man right but for a woman you know
it's flip a coin as to what you should do the
angel tater i know you've interviewed and we're
working on getting him on valuetainment we're in
discussions right now he tells this story and i
think it's so true because i've been on these
types of parties uh these yacht parties where
there's four guys and a hundred women and he tells
the story he's like you show me a yacht right and
there's four guys on this yacht all right and a
hundred women and there is no telling what these
four men had to do what kind of contribution to
society they had how much work ethic they needed
to have how much people they needed to employ
and impress and deals and wheeling and dealing
and maybe by the time they're 60 [__] years old
they get to kick back relax halfway bald and fat
probably by the way but at least enjoy the spoils
of the luxury of their labor whereas you have a
hundred women who are 20 to 30 years old and all
they had to go do was buy some [__] lipstick
hey i've never been on a yacht okay well you're
how do i get on here i've not been on a yacht
how is that even possible i've not been on new
york because you're a boss babe you're not just
using your sexuality to what's a boss babe well
like a working woman a woman who's like making
you know her own money never heard that like
i've heard it but i think boss babe has really
negative connotations i agree well babe is
like boss babe is like i'm a boss [__] i
don't need no man like [__] men like that's
not me i agree i mean i agree with you however
making your own money and making carving
your own niche in this world is you
but i just think that's human survival you
think so who else is going to pay my bills
well according to a lot of women out there a man
which one well you got to find i mean i'm on it
i gotta have somewhere to live do i live
on the streets and to do i will get a
sugar daddy no i don't want that yeah a
lot of women do i know her own money so
she can get to the great places where
the men are yeah let's talk about this
let's talk about this i like gideon kind
of being a great uh segway over there
wait one thing you didn't mention i don't
know if they can i hope you guys can hear him
speaking this if the man makes one million
dollars he's willing to spend it all on his
girl to protect her provide her if the woman makes
a million dollars she will not spend a dime she'll
keep it all in the bank that's a huge point yeah
that's what you were saying that's what you yeah
exactly that's what you were saying and i
think um that is true um that's 100 true um
once you get into that relationship um but
what you you ask oh yeah so yeah that that
boss babe thing it's interesting because i come
from a small little town just outside of london
right and i can you know get a secretary
job and just work a nine-to-five and not
make a lot of money but it means i'm stuck in
that situation where everyone's fat and gray
and old right so there's no high value men or
women right nobody cares about anything in that
situation right okay so i'm like so what do i
need to do to let's say meet a man that i think
would be equal value to me or you know someone
that i would like and be happy with well i'm sure
you discussed this before but the whole concept of
hypergamy right yeah you did this with rolo when
you're like how much how tall does a guy need to
be yeah how much money does he need to make what
does he need to bring to the table you know women
will only date across and above right so men will
they'll bang the hot chick that works at starbucks
or the waitress or whatever or they'll take
you know the ceo type girl out there you know
the attractive uh pundit you know type person out
there so roles are different so right but and what
i'm saying is like everyone from that town was was
was below right so as a woman i want to date
across or up so everyone was below so now i'm live
right but how do i afford that i got to make
money and so i make money and i i i did well
and you know things are going well which is
great um but now i'm like apparently this
boss [__] that doesn't need no money i don't
i never called you a [__] that's just oh sorry
no you have like the difference between you and
those girls is you actually number one have a
good understanding of the world number two you
have a good attitude a lot of those women have
really horrible attitudes and they kind of like
have a disdain for men and they just kind of like
they look at men as like a cash register an atm
and yeah i can't believe this chick is asking you
for a grand yeah that's awful yeah well you know
that blows my mind sorry i interrupted you but
yes you were talking about how uh women have
this negative um relationship towards men yeah
well the the look you're gonna be okay let me try
what was the initial question though i don't know
it's just going back and forth at this point we're
talking about feminism why it's gonna mess things
up well the i but this is backs to my whole point
is that women there's a lack of clarity should
you go and find a man and be a housewife should
you carve your own career i'm an advocate of
women getting their own career like i don't i get
whether it i don't think it's just all men working
like how annoying is that just all men what what
zero interaction with females in the world so
i am an advocate of women working but the whole
thing is like your brother you know so pointlessly
pointed out the women aren't going to spend their
money on the man so it's the man's job to provide
and be the man and especially in a relationship
um whereas all the money that women wait makes you
know they spend on themselves it's hard being a
woman you think it's easy like i've lived with
girls okay it's really hard yeah like you need
money to just to walk out of your house every
day makeup hair nails clothes like i could have
my nails down this week kind of a guy could roll
up out of bed and just like throw on a t-shirt
like yo what up we're going to the gym like it's
much harder to be a woman but at the same time
it's much easier to be a woman in certain social
settings like don't forget a lot of my um you know
the reason that i deal with money and game and all
that just don't forget i remember being 16 18 20
years old going out to clubs in south beach and if
i went with three of my buddies we wouldn't get in
but if i went with three girls i would get in
and be in the vip for official okay so i'm like
holy [__] i'm learning things here dudes are
kryptonite to a club unless you're buying bottles
unless you're spending cash right and i've been
in more clubs than probably most people in this
freaking world okay and i haven't spent a lot of
money because i'm again a great networker i know
all the people in the clubs and the scene
like that's just what i do but to be a man
like i i i because i interview a lot of people
and i'll remember i go to people in the south
like guys groups of guys what up guys like how
was your time in south beach [__] hated here man
we didn't get into any clubs bro yeah well
did you drop loot no we weren't gonna spend
two grand on a table well it's like would you
want seven dudes in your club not spending money
no no but seven girls could roll up and they'll
give them a free bottle just to hang out
so to say that men and women aren't different in
some capacity especially when it comes to money
and sexual market value would be a complete
lie so no matter what it is women are going
to bring certain things to the table and men
are going to bring certain things to the table
men are going to have to bring money to the table
a lot of the cases women are going to have to
bring attractiveness yes fertility and a good damn
attitude yeah i have a story for you as well um so
when i was 20 i'd go to all the clubs in london
and it's the same vibe right it's like women
getting free promoters bottles notice how whether
it's miami or london or sydney or hong kong it's
the same vibe 100 men spend money women look good
boom but it's [__] and i'll tell you why because
i obviously was living with my parents at the time
and my dad every time i'd come home in the morning
would be like did you meet any nice guys and i'm
like no dad because you know who's in this damn
club because i have no money so i'm 20. because so
i go there to get them for free fat old men are in
there i'm 20 i don't want to be i don't want to
be partying with fat old men and so i'm there
with these young girls we're all having a great
time looking you know our best super youthful
and amazing whatever and the the waiter that work
that he said to us um girls we'll give you a free
bottle of champagne if you could just entertain
our clients and i'm like you're speaking to like
three really like well-raised jewish girls here
we're not entertaining any of your clients like
we don't need your champagne and these were like
really old fat men that wanted us to entertain
whatever that meant yeah and we're just like we're
raised way too well for this no um but so you
know what happens if they weren't fat and old and
they were actually good-looking guys in their 30s
but they're not that's the thing they know what
are you talking about they never work they never
were i i went i from i was like i went to a lot of
clubs in london from like 18 to maybe like 22 and
i was bored um and now i don't go clubbing i just
talk that was what rolo calls your whole face not
that you were putting out or anything like that i
never did i never did sorry boys no i i i i never
ever did but no i look it's what girls just want
to have fun it's a free time to cindy love it yeah
it's a free time to dance to some music with your
girlfriends and have a great time um but no there
were never ever ever any attractive men in there
and dad every time i came home would say meet any
nice guys no dad no maybe it was just a horrible
club because you know i went to all of them in
london pretty attractive men and women no not
in london um yeah so that's why i'm always like
yeah it's cool you know you get to go into clubs
for free as a young woman but it's like and but
it's like the kind of men that that attracts isn't
what you're looking for because men can't get in
unless they put down a ton of money and
sometimes men don't even want to put down a
ton of money you know and i understand that why
would you like you said you become a minimalist
yeah like the chances of me spending
thousands of dollars at a club at this
point in my life are so non-existent
exactly because i've already done that
okay so you know like that as you grow you learn
a lot but you know this it's just i've been to
clubs you know venues yachts parties like you know
the whole you know wedding that i was a part of
i don't know if you're familiar with that whole
thing like i've had experience with the richest
of the richest and now it's like i just want to
be secure with my own situation so the um that
but you have to learn that as you grow older
like you know women i feel like 30 is a major
age for women women look at 30 and they you know
i'm 25. i'm freaking out you're perfect right now
but women you know reach an age at 30 that they
kind of like all right biological clocks tick in
like what am i going to do but men i feel like
for most men that age is 40. when i turned 40 a
year ago i was like what the [__] am i doing i
broke up with my girl i got this guy i got no it's
got you like so men and women age differently so
i learned that from none other than kim kardashian
by the way what did you what happened well when
she was 30 yeah um she was dating my best friend
at the time well still one of my best friends wait
i know nothing about pop culture but having spent
um some time in miami earlier this year um is
that the really tall guy yeah yeah what's his name
his name is chris humphries uh he was at a gemini
party i went to i had no idea someone just pointed
him out to me and i was like oh okay at the uh
winklevoss yes yeah we were at the same party
had i noticed i bumped into you yeah he was at
the podium you were drunk great memory i was
not drunk there was hot guys there why that that
one tyler and cameron winklevoss were there tyron
county yeah that they were if miami was there
he's also attractive yeah okay yeah well anyway
i was there with him and like that crew um so
yeah well as the story goes um so i used to be a
pretty good basketball player like i played
college football a little college basketball
uh and i used to network a lot with a lot of nba
guys and um i used to play basketball with that
guy chris humphries back in the day and actually
minneapolis where my mom is from in the summers
uh we kept in touch when he came down to miami he
made it to the nba he was 19. he couldn't get into
any of the clubs so he would call me we would get
him into the club i don't think there's any like
uh statue of limitations like getting an underage
person in the club in uh 2004 but they're going to
come for you they're going to come for me so we'd
get we'd party together uh we went from being like
friends to good friends to one of his best friends
and fast forward the guy's six nine he's made
50 million in the nba he's a good looking dude
like if he ever tries to give me like i remember
this one i'll tell the kim kardashian store but
chris would always tell all right guys like this
is advice to like how you should pick up chicks
and i go dude shut the [__] up don't even talk
anymore you're six nine you're good looking dude
you're worth 50 million don't tell all the rest
of us your advice like save it that's like if like
giselle bunchen walked in she's like ladies listen
this is how you land a high value man
it's like you're a goddamn supermodel
you have to stand there and look good save it
anyway so chris calls me one day out of the blue
and he goes what up um say what's up to my girl
she goes hey what's up adam what's going on you
know we're coming down to miami next week i go who
is this she goes it's kim silly i'm like kim who
it's kim kardashian like i'm like is this like
and it sounds like her right i'm like what is
happening right now i gotta throw chris back on
the phone i go dude who are you with right now
he's like dude just like play cool like yeah turns
out it was kim kardashian and um they had this
fairytale romance she was 30 years old back to my
entire beginning point she had just turned 30 and
she was quote unquote freaking out that she wasn't
married yet and she was dating my boy and my boy's
got a move where he tells a girl i love you within
like the first 10 minutes hey i think i love you
like most people probably take a year to tell a
girl that right that's like his move and they boom
fall in love get engaged the whole deal i like i
take a year out of my life to be a kardashian i'm
not even kidding like we fly to mexico together
we're on trips together i'm staying at kim's house
in la beverly hills like and we do this whole
wedding they fly us out uh zenya tuxedos the
whole like the whole thing like i'm walking khloe
kardashian down the aisle like the whole thing
like google it whatever but like i'm thinking
we're friends i didn't know that yeah well this
is why you ask these questions on podcasts
but so this whole thing happens and i'm like
like friends are hitting me up like dude you know
kim karda like what is happening right now right
and boom like that like they divorce after like 72
days and i called her because we were friends like
she's my age 41 years old um currently and she and
i go kim like uh what happened she goes you know
you know i was in a hurry to get married because
we've had these conversations before because
chris is five years younger than me chris is 37
years 36 years or whatever he is um she goes yeah
i just i kind of rushed into it she's like there's
not a phone call and i go well best of luck i hope
like the next wedding works out better for you
genuinely and she goes oh honey i'm the modern
day elizabeth taylor i'll probably be married a
dozen times her words i swear to god and elizabeth
taylor i think was married like eight or nine
times now kim has gone through i don't know
kanye she's gonna chew this guy pete davidson
out like he'll move on to something else
you'll see what's gonna happen with this girl but
back to my initial point this all really stemmed
because she was 30 and freaking out so um but
there is some validity to that because if we go
back to my initial point before that you know 45
percent of women are going to be non-married and
no kids by the time they're 20 30. and if like
your goal of a woman is to get married and have
kids you need to reassess what you're doing
with your life because men don't care about
your job description or much money you make they
care about different things so on that point and
i think this might be my final question on that
point then um something i'm really curious about
i think this is i think the answer is different
for different men um so let's get your take does
it put you off um whether a woman is um
successful um and also what she does for
work right um because of course it's different
if she's like the ceo and suited and booted of
this company i get that's kind of off-putting um
but yeah does it put you off if a woman has money
no i don't think it puts you off so um
because i get you don't care that's fine no i
because i do care i i'll tell you not
about the money about what they do
i've dated i've never dated a woman who's more
successful than me okay even when i didn't have
money i dated a girl like we were both just
kind of like in our 20s figuring things out
but well a lot of the girls i tend to date
are younger and that whole thing but um
i i don't care like i just want a woman who can
actually just pay her own bills because nothing
is worse than having like kind of a leech
of a girl that can't pay her own bills so um
some guys are okay with that like like a woman
should have something she's definitely passionate
about because like to just expect a woman to
just sit home and all day and take care of the
kids and the family and make sandwiches is really
undermining of the value of a woman a woman should
have something that they're passionate about i
don't care if that's yoga or bitcoin or you know
pick a thing photography something that
like drives them that motivates them
but also you know at the same time congruently
taking care of the family taking care of a man
women have gone down this path where they
need to be educated they need to make money
you know whether they believe it or not don't
need a man because they can pay their own bills
um where does that end where does that and
where do they end up i'll tell you a story
that really resonated to me on my 40th birthday
um at bodega here not here but you know in bodega
and down in miami um the uh it was my 40th
birthday and all my friends were there and
um i was single i'd recently broken up
with a girl and my boy shows up um miguel
and he goes yo what up salsa where are you
bro you're killing it bro you're 40 now
you got money you're looking good bro you're
killing it valuetainment like like dude you're
killing it bro i'm so proud of you i'm like
yo thank you brother he goes oh [__] is that
laura over there who we went to high school
with i go yeah he goes what's up with her
again same age i go yeah yeah she's doing
good she married yet bro no uh she got kids
no i don't think so man what's she up to i'm like
yeah she's still working he goes damn that sucks
and i go oh damn there it is like if you ever
need a case example i learned it on my 40th
birthday where i like spent the minute being
like damn poor laura over there where adam 40
successful high value whatever but like he's like
dude you're the [__] man and her he she's like
what happened to her because she was like
the hottest thing in high school and a lot
of times women will you know in their 20s what i
haven't got nothing to lose i'm all good 26. cool
guys are coming at me i'm 30. okay i'm kind of
freaking out a little bit now but i'm still 30 and
i'm making money next thing you know you're 35 and
the guys who were approaching you now they're more
approaching the new batch of 21 25 year old chicks
and you're kind of like you're still hot you're 35
but next thing you know you're 40 and you're laura
and the guys that pursued you before they're like
yeah yeah i'm good like i'll take new laura who's
10 years younger because guys care about guys are
visual whereas women aren't as visual creatures
um so i i'll never always tell that story about my
friend by the way her real name is laura because
i don't want to put her [__] out there like that
um and i always remember like okay 40 year old
adam pimp stud doing his thing 40 year old laura
went went sad story and i feel bad because lawyer
is awesome but laura you know probably should have
doubled down on a dude who was in love with her
10 years prior but she was like i'll do better
and then that that prince charming never
came around yeah it breaks my heart
yeah i see it in your face you're like no it
hurts me it breaks my heart became a dead flower
kid stop is that what happened it doesn't break
let me know let me ask you a question careful
with your questions do you think how much time
i have we have like 10 minutes okay do you think
genuine question mm-hmm that you'll ever meet
a man you love as much as you love bitcoin
i bloody well hope so yeah that's like man
before bitcoin for sure really yeah how do
i come across like come across as like this
hard yeah clarify what you want in a man yeah
like i i like for me like i want to be a
wife why like i don't understand everyone's
so surprised every time i say that i'm not
surprised i'm just i like i feel like you love
bitcoin yeah i don't think like bitcoins look
bitcoin's not giving me children and it's not like
being it's not holding me at night is it no maybe
i hold my bitcoin i need something to huddle me
maybe your bit max account maybe you're just like
oh that's so weird adam that's so not cool no
so you think you that you could put a man before
bitcoin i know i could put a man before bitcoin oh
for sure i put a man before a lot of things yeah i
just unfortunately haven't met anyone that i'm in
love with like i've i've loved but i haven't like
been like wow like you are somebody that i want to
give my future to i think love is giving a
future to someone and i haven't met anyone
that i want to give my future to and that i
have been in relationships and i and i've broke
them off because i'm like you're not the one that
i want to marry and i don't want to waste time
um and i'm looking for the
one that i want to marry 100
yeah i think um i say this all the time men you
should waste your 20s as much as possible agreed
waste your 20s like i wasted my 20s zero
regrets women can waste their early 20s yeah
do not waste your mid-20s because if you waste
your mid-20s you're going to wake up one day and
you're going to be 30 and you're going to be like
the kim kardashian story and you're just going to
marry the first guy that tells you he loves you
and that's not going to work out well so men and
women are different but i appreciate women beyond
um but like they they they need to understand like
the future like you said uh you said so eloquently
like i i put my future how did you describe that
love is giving someone else your future yeah it's
amazing yeah and i just haven't met anyone that i
want to give my future to yet um you know and it
means giving up many different things which are we
don't need to get into what do you mean get into
them i'd rather not on my project but we're not
this podcast from what i understand is where the
conversations that nobody wants to have other
places your party takes place we can have them
on the sauce cast podcast okay i'll come on your
podcast i'll come back into the studio and we'll
have like comments on bitcoin we'll have this
awkward conversation we'll have this awkward
conversation what is the point of contention
here right now put in like the point of contention
that you won't answer what the setting the setting
their time in and we can speak about that offer
okay all right i think i'm going to end it there
adam i want to thank you so much for coming on
it's been a lot of fun um i really appreciate your
insight on finance you had a lot to say i love
this conversation um i love everything you've done
and major congrats on moving and shifting
and everything that you're building um
it's great to have you on it guys please follow
adam's cast podcast valuetainment they're doing
amazing on youtube um i give a plug please go go
follow us on valuetainment and then my channel is
called valuetainmentmoney um and we've got a lot
of exciting things that are coming up right now
with some new talent that we're signing an a-list
hollywood actor is now coming to valuetainment
uh one of the ladies jedediah bila
she just left well she was on the view
she's now on valuetainment and we've got a
bunch of surprises that are coming up we're
doing a major event in south florida you know
uh x amount of uh 100 000 miles that way um
and uh we're gonna have robert kiyosaki there
and a bunch of uh chas palmitari a bunch of uh
kevin connolly amazing um amazing things and uh so
follow us on valuetainment and you can follow my
personal channel on saucetalksmoney on instagram
and by the way just to just free plug for you for
me for everyone there's a lot of fake accounts out
there for mine i've i've gotten hit up by multiple
leia halliburtons don't give anybody crypto
because they dm'd you yeah anybody that's my
problem with the crypto these days like there's a
lot of scammers out there but that's a whole other
topic don't send anybody money just because they
dm you yeah no thank you for saying that actually
uh because a very good friend of mine um just got
scammed at 400 because they thought it was me so
that's problematic but adam thank you so much um
and guys thank you so much for watching i hope
you found this valuable and also don't forget
um if you do want to buy the dip right now then
bitmex is the place to go a huge thank you
to bitmakes because without them we wouldn't
be able to bring you such important content and
while you're here please don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and the like button and we'll
see you all next week the leia hill pen show
you